this caused lots of conversation this
film lots of conversation I was like
Washington and I'm like did I see what I
just saw it whatever freakin right now
what is going on am I really up like
what just happened here I will give you
ten million dollars drunk my husband in
the ocean for the sharks Anne Hathaway
and Matthew McConaughey are back
together on screen in the sexy new
thriller serenity this one is a
conversation piece like you gotta talk
about it afterwards did you guys know
immediately when do you were doing
interstellar like I gotta get back with
her I gotta get back with him and work
together immediately I knew I enjoyed
working with him right away and would
welcome the opportunity to do it again
anyway when she came on board with this
I was like pardon
yes I really enjoy working with her yeah
same for you I wanted work here again I
knew that very consciously and I think I
manifested it you speak it out there
that's half the battle you keep saying
it and it's definitely gonna happen I
felt very lucky when I met Matthew and
interstellar because he was it's it's
very unusual you can admire factors from
afar I had and to meet someone up close
and realize he's living his life he's
found the balance that I am striving for
so I just knew that I wanted Matthew in
my life in some kind of influential way
and I hoped that I'd be able to continue
to work with him do I get to learn as an
actor and also learned a lot on stage at
the Oscars she closed the show back in
2011 with James Franco what's the
toughest part though about hosting the
Oscars the most challenging day feels
nice everybody tells you it's going well
so why you're doing it everyone's while
you're doing it it's like doing it it's
you're just doing I remember being
backstage at that time and seeing you
and yeah it seemed like it to me
you know what was yeah I'm very I
approached all this stuff is really
simple
we're lucky I was gonna this stuff is
you know this is whether or not it it it
does well or a bombs this is missed
dreams this is nice I'm going to get
upset about this is not something to now
that being said when it really bombs it
does I said I am one of those people
that I look at though the win is you did
it they asked you to do it and you did
it that's the win I think it might wind
up being a net positive over life but
but no easily and that possibility
sure well the lesson the lessons that I
learned the life lessons about who to
trust and how to trust them that's gonna
wind up being in that positive what do
you think about all this hoopla that's
been made about trying to lock down a
host and have you been reached out to
like be one of the psuedo like
presenters or anything for this year I
have no idea but I'm feeling it by then
reached out nobody would tell me no stay
away look I think it's a longer
conversation that being said I do just
want to go on record as saying I think
the LGBTQ community needs all the allies
in the world
100% and deserves all the allies a
movement
[Music]